i love this sound
hello jq this is tromme and this is my
10 essentials
[Music]
so one of my essentials is one ring it's
called the clue from cartier some years
ago i just wanted to have a little bit
of jewelry on on my hands kohli my wife
decided to
offer me this beautiful ring for my
35th birthday yeah i love it it's in
pink gold and yeah i wear it on this
finger and
it's beautiful
also cartier
invited me for the next med gala
in new york so it's uh something for me
especially for my wife to be honest
because every year my wife is watching
the med gala i watch it too but but not
as
involved as my wife and i'm really proud
to be there i hope it's going to be fun
but i'm sure it's going to be fun
so my next essential is a gift from
giaziro cult
watches company i received it i don't
remember i think it was in 2015 or
something it's uh the
reverse reverso it was made for the
apollo players you can reverse it so
that's
the reason why it's called the reverso
and it protects the watch actually
while you were playing polo it's an
expensive watch and uh i really wanted
to keep that
my entire life and give that to my son
one day and say okay you know i wore
this this watch and and and i'm so proud
to give that to you you have to wind it
manually and there is a beautiful sound
which is
i love this sound
my corda sote in french we say
it's a jump rope i just learned the word
thank you for the english courses yeah
that's my new routine before going on
stage uh 10 minutes or 15 minutes of
jump rope to be just fresh hot and do my
best i feel fresh i don't know to have a
second breath that's really good to uh
to warm um yeah my muscles a little bit
before going on stage because i love to
dance yeah i have to be ready to go on
stage and
that's the best way to be ready
so another gift from my wife is my
beautiful
backpack every time i go on a trip uh
yeah i i take this this bag uh to have
all my items my 10 essentials yeah i
think it's beautiful i we bought it
she bought it sorry uh in bruges it's a
city from belgium it's like it's called
the small venice it's not like venice in
italy but yeah there is a lot of water
in the city and we went there uh
as a romantic trip and she bought me
this beautiful bag it's funny because
she checked that out on internet she
wanted to buy it and then we just passed
by the shop and i said well i love this
bag and she said you know what i just
wanted to give you to to to offer that
that bag for your birthday i was so
happy i don't know if it was for my
birthday i think it was for christmas it
was for christmas
[Music]
you know when you don't have lotion on
your skin you you gray
oh you say
ashy thank you very much for that so
yeah lotion is really important for me
my wife made me discover this brand it's
a french brand really natural natural
ingredient um really good for your skin
that's really good
it's really important for me to start
the day to have a good lotion uh that's
really important to be in a good mood
that's i'm not i'm not joking that's
really important for me
i bump into this this sneaker when i was
looking for sustainable brands on the
internet and i discover a sustainable
version of the sneaker so i bought it
and it was really comfortable so i
bought a new one and i love the color of
this one like pastel colors and
they are so comfortable
and i love yeah i love wearing this i
was a little bit extremist back in the
days because i was trying like to have
an entire life like it's completely
sustainable but i realized that it's not
possible you know you can't be like
perfect so i'm just trying to do my best
and that's something that we do with our
brand sustainability
ethic recycled materials as a consumer i
try to be a
good consumer too so i try to do my best
but i can't be perfect so
so the next
essential is my uh mini keys that's
something else that we that we do is
collaborations and one of the
collaboration was a a car that we
designed with mini an electric car uh
that we released uh one year ago coralie
luca and myself were working with the
graphist we have a beautiful pattern on
the
on the roof and the logo somewhere on
the car and we decided everything like
the color of the car and everything i
couldn't even imagine to design a car
one day in my life they proposed us to
work with them so that was pretty
obvious for us to just try something new
a new experience mini
so one of my essentials is at least one
piece of the mossad collection so mossar
is the brand that we launched with my
wife and my brother in 2014 and so
that's one of the piece
this is simply the logo one beautiful
cloud with blue green and pink i wear
always at least one piece of the mossad
collection to be honest i'm not the
designer it's my wife corelli parpie i
think that's a way of expression and
that's something i love to do this is
another design from my wife also and
it's funny because we were just
discussing about that yesterday because
we don't follow the seasons and
everything you know we don't want to do
like just for doing stuff we have to be
uh yeah convinced it has to make sense
and uh
we were just thinking about it that's
some stuff that i love to do discuss
about clothes closing lines
sustainability a lot of things
it's a hair ties you don't call that
elastic
elastic too okay
so that's really important for me now
because i have long hair
i let them grow since 2015. if you meet
me in the street like you see me in the
street i'm always wearing a bun it's a
difficult job
and especially for the long hair every
time i have to go on set for here for
example i have to work with the
hairstylist for half an hour i'm lucky
because i have a hair stylist but
actually when you don't you have to do
it yourself and that's difficult
so the next essential is a notebook
pretty new i just bought it
in cvs
the other day it's not the same putting
something on your phone and writing down
on on notebook in a notebook it stays
longer in your brain i think when you
write it manually and it's so easy to
have a note in uh on your phone that you
have like thousand of of it and you
never go back on it to be honest i'm
lost in my notes on my phone so i
decided to buy the new a new real
notebook
let's do an ad for apple yeah that's
the
most important object of my professional
life i would say i made my entire album
on this computer so i do my produce my
my my beats on a program called reason
by propellerhead actually i have two
moods like the composition mode is i'm
completely focused like
working on my compositions from nine to
five and that's it i do no promotion no
concert
then uh the album is done and then i
start to do promotion interviews and and
concerts and i try to compose but it's
it's not the same mood and i'm not as as
inspired as the in the period of
composition because i think to have
something interesting i need more than
six months of trying having
bad productions and thanks to my brother
i know that it's bad because sometimes
you're convinced that it's really good
but actually thanks to
your good friends or your creative
director you learn that it's not really
good for example for for multitude i
wanted to have a lot of influence from
traditional music from all around the
world and at the very beginning it was a
little bit too calculated to uh not
natural
and then after one year
when you get used to it when it goes
like completely natural
it's it goes more
i don't know
good uh just good
spontaneity spontaneous
sorry yeah yeah it's more spontaneous
because at the very beginning it's not
it's not natural and
and after one year like trying and
trying and trying it become
spontaneous thank you gq and see you
next time bye